el siguiente acertijo es uno de los
clásicos en el mundo de los acertijos y
aunque tal vez muchos de ustedes ya lo
han escuchado decidí incluirlo en esta
sección de acertijos pues creo que este
acertijo es muy buen comienzo para
acertijos de un nivel mucho mayor y
además para entender quién es aquel que
dice la verdad y quién es aquel que dice
la mentira y de hecho el acertijo se
llama el honesto y el mentiroso el
acertijo del honesto y el mentiroso y
bueno el problema consiste en lo
siguiente yo tengo dos puertas
voy a dibujarlas yo tengo dos puertas
esta va a ser una de mis puertas
y tengo otra puerta aquí bien y ahora
detrás de una puerta está un tesoro
padrísimo que me puedo encontrar sin
embargo detrás de la otra puerta al
abrirla yo tengo una dolorosa y lenta
muerte y además voy a desatar toda la
miseria de este mundo y las crueldades
más fuertes que ustedes pueden pensar
casi como en la caja de pandora por lo
tanto tengo que tener mucho cuidado en
cuanto a las dos puertas voy a elegir y
bueno sentados al lado de las dos
puertas hay dos tipos uno de ellos
parece a este y el otro de ellos se ve
más o menos así y bueno curiosamente
también sé no sé supongamos que vinieron
y me dijeron los grandes dioses del
acertijo que ambos cuates tienen el
conocimiento de cuál es la puerta que
tiene el premio y el tesoro más
apremiado del mundo y también saben cuál
es la puerta que tiene mi muerte más
tremenda y más horrible que se puedan
imaginar y la inimaginable e increíble
desesperación mundial entonces ambos
saben que puerta debería de abrir y más
aún ellos saben que uno
y siempre dice la verdad es decir
siempre es honesto y el otro siempre
miente es decir siempre es un mentiroso
entonces uno de ellos siempre es honesto
y el otro siempre miente y yo no sé
quién es quién de ellos el problema yo
no sé quién siempre miente y quién
siempre dice la verdad y bueno también
hay que agregarle que solamente tengo
una oportunidad digo ya saben no puedo
venir y abrió una de las puertas porque
si abre la puerta equivocada
inmediatamente la desesperación va a
salir y va a matar y entonces todo el
miedo se se esparciera y bueno entonces
el problema consiste en lo siguiente yo
solamente tengo una oportunidad de
hacerle a uno de ellos una pregunta
entonces cuál va a ser la pregunta
correcta ya quién de los dos personajes
el de verde o el de café le voy a hacer
esa pregunta es decir cuál es la
pregunta correcta a quién de los dos le
voy a hacer esa pregunta y cómo puedo
asegurar que la respuesta de esa
pregunta me va a decir la puerta
indicada que debo de abrir recuerden que
uno de ellos siempre miente y el otro
siempre es honesto y bueno a partir de
ahora viene la solución si ustedes no
quieren saber todavía la solución sería
bueno que pausar en el vídeo y pensarán
el problema lo pueden pensar los 20
minutos media hora un día de hecho
pensar un día no sería malo hay veces
que en la noche llegan las ideas
brillantes de cómo resolver este tipo de
acertijos entonces pausa en los pares en
este vídeo porque aquí viene la solución
como no sabemos quién de los dos tipos
dice la verdad y dice la mentira y
además solamente tenemos una pregunta
que realizar
uno solo de los dos personajes que
tenemos aquí entonces la pregunta
correcta sería cuál puerta diría el otro
personaje el otro la persona que tiene
enfrente que es la puerta correcta para
abrir es decir supongamos que me acerco
al tipo de verde y entonces yo les voy a
preguntar qué va a decir el tipo de café
que es la puerta correcta para abrir a
ver supongamos que el guante de verde
dice la verdad entonces qué va a pasar
el otro parte sería el mentiroso el
cuate de café sería que dice la mentira
y yo con él de verdad le pregunto qué
puerta va a decir que abra el tipo de
café y entonces si el cuate de café es
el mentiroso va a pasar lo siguiente
primero quiero que nos fijemos qué va a
pasar si yo llego con el tipo de café y
le pregunto cuál es la puerta correcta
bueno como él es un mentiroso entonces
me va a decir la puerta incorrecta me va
a señalar la puerta incorrecta ahora
bien como yo le estoy preguntando al
tipo de verde qué es lo que diría el
tipo de café que es la puerta correcta
pues bueno como el tipo de verde siempre
dice la verdad entonces me va a
contestar la respuesta de la persona de
café es decir la puerta incorrecta
entonces en el caso en el que el tipo de
verde dice la verdad y el tipo de café
es el mentiroso yo obtengo como
resultado la puerta incorrecta ahora qué
va a pasar si es al revés si al que le
pregunto es el tipo de verde pero él es
el mentiroso y el tipo de café es el que
dice siempre la verdad recuerden que yo
no sé quién dice la verdad y quién dice
la mentira entonces como el mentiroso no
tiene de otra siempre me va a decir la
mentira si yo le pregunto qué va a decir
el tipo de café que es el que dice la
verdad
la puerta correcta pues no le ha quedado
transmitida que mentir entonces el tipo
si yo tuviera mucha suerte y le
preguntará el tipo de café cuál es la
puerta correcta pues él me diría la
puerta correcta él siempre dice la
verdad supongamos que la puerta correcta
es la de la derecha le voy a poner el
número 2 y a este oops no no no perdón a
este le voy a poner el número 2 y a la
puerta de la izquierda le voy a poner el
número 1 entonces la puerta correcta es
la puerta de la derecha si yo llego con
el personaje de café y le pregunto cuál
es la puerta correcta pues me va a decir
hombre es la de la derecha pero ahora
qué pasa si yo le pregunto al mentiroso
que cuál es la puerta que mediría el
personaje de café que es la correcta
bueno como el mentiroso ambiente
entonces no me va a decir la puerta 2 me
va a decir la puerta 1 porque me está
mintiendo por lo tanto me da de
resultado también la puerta incorrecta
otra vez por lo tanto como no importa la
persona a la que la haga a esta pregunta
siempre voy a obtener la respuesta
incorrecta
entonces ya tengo el resultado yo llego
con una persona sin saber si es el
mentiroso o el que dice siempre la
verdad y le hago esta pregunta qué pie
la persona de enfrente que es la puerta
correcta y obtengo siempre la respuesta
incorrecta
entonces pues elijo la otra puerta yo
llevo pone la persona de verde y le digo
oye qué piensa la persona que hace que
esa puerta correcta y él me responde la
persona de café dice que la puerta
correcta es la puerta número 1 por lo
tanto yo no voy a abrir la puerta número
1 porque voy a obtener todo el dolor y
el sufrimiento del mundo entonces yo voy
a abrir la puerta número 2 la puerta
contraria esta sería la puerta correcta
y de manera análoga si la persona de
verde me dice que su respuesta es la
puerta número 2 por lo tanto voy a abrir
la puerta número 1 espero que este
acertijo le sirva bastante para resolver
los acertijos que siguen en los
siguientes vídeos